What Unobtainium really is
In the 2009 film, Avatar, the events of the
film are set in motion by the desire to acquire
a rare mineral of unfathomable value known
simply as “unobtainium”.
The unimaginative, seemingly lazy naming of
this mysterious substance drew the ire and
scorn of several critics, many of whom seemed
blissfully unaware that aeronautical engineers
and scientists have been talking about unobtainium
since the 1950s.
So what is unobtainium and who named it?
Although it isn’t clear who first coined
the term “unobtainium”, the first known
documented case of it appeared in the February
27, 1956 edition of the Marshall, Michigan
Evening Chronicle where it stated, “The
metal is so hard to come by that the scientists
have devised a lugubriously-humorous name
for it.
They call it ‘unobtainium.'”
The next known documented instance occurred
in the 1957 Ohio based newspaper, The Zanesville
Signal.
In it, Major General William O. Senter, the
chief of procurement and production at Wright-Patterson
Air Force Base, explained that the Air Force
was currently looking for a virtually weightless
material that was simultaneously “infinitely
strong” and easy to work with.
Senter went on to explain that this wonder
material also needed to be able to “resist
any degree of heat” while being “available
at negligible cost”.
The Major General then jokingly added that
although the Air Force had yet to find such
a substance, they did have a name for it-
“unobtainium“.
Just one year later, in 1958, unobtainium
was officially defined by the Interim Glossary
of Aero Space Terms as a noun that refers
to:
“A substance having the exact high test
properties required for a piece of hardware
or other item of use, but not obtainable either
because it theoretically cannot exist or because
technology is insufficiently advanced to produce
it.”
In that glossary, and all subsequent reproductions
of it, the word is listed as being “humorous
or ironical”, a sort of inside-joke amongst
engineers and scientists.
However, just because the word is often used
jokingly doesn’t mean it doesn’t have
a useful place in the world of science as
a shorthand way of talking about a material
that possesses the exact set of properties
you need for a given project, but for whatever
reason you either can’t get a hold of the
substance or it simply doesn’t exist yet.
In the latter case, it certainly is slightly
more professional sounding than using something
like the word “thingy” when drawing up
specs and discussing design elements.
But even when the substance already has a
name and very much does exist, “unobtainium”
is still sometimes used.
For example, during the Cold War, titanium
was sometimes referred to by U.S. engineers
as unobtainium due to its various properties
being perfect for many aerospace applications,
but almost nobody in the States could get
their hands on any real quantity of it due
to the Soviet Union controlling most of the
world’s supply at the time.
An example where the unobtainium simply didn’t
exist yet was with the Rockwell X-30, a proposed
hypersonic aircraft from the 1990s that was
conceived as a “passenger space liner”
capable of travelling perhaps as high as Mach
25.
For much of the craft’s initial development,
many engineers dismissed the possibility of
such a craft existing, stating that it would
need to be constructed out of unobtainium
to have the necessary weight, strength, and
durability requirements, while also able to
survive continually oscillating between low
temperatures and then being exposed to several
thousand degrees Fahrenheit as it traveled
at ultra high speeds.
However, shortly before funding for the X-30
was cut (mostly due to budget concerns), this
particular “unobtainium” was created in
the form of a carbon-carbon composite covered
with a silicon-carbide ceramic coating.
According to an interview with Dr. Terry Ronald,
the deputy director of materials for the project,
this substance addressed many of the problems
detractors had pointed out years prior.
James_Webb_Telescope_ModelFor a more contemporary
example, consider the Integrated Science Instrument
Module, part of the James Webb Space Telescope
project due to launch in 2018 if there are
no further delays.
The ISIM also made use of something referred
to as unobtainium, in the form of a needed
material that hadn’t been invented yet when
the telescope was initially being designed.
NASA later described this design process as
being like: “building a car chassis without
a blueprint or even a list of recommended
construction materials.”
However, they came up with a solution in the
end, creating a “never-before-manufactured
composite material” capable of surviving
“temperatures that plunged as low as 27
Kelvin (-411 degrees Fahrenheit), colder than
the surface
of Pluto.”